all right people it's thursday september
9th
2021
five days away
from when we say goodbye to evil disney
cartoon character gavin newsom as
governor of california and we elect my
friend and great human being and
wonderful american and just decent soul
larry elder to be the next governor
we're going to get to that in just a
second
but i want to say first i don't think
i've ever been this fired up to do a
show just generally speaking there's
just so much going on right now but also
this is kinda my first real show
back on the grid because you know i came
back a week ago yesterday with adam
corolla we got caught up to speed the
following day thursday i did a q a then
friday we did that glenn beck show all
about afghanistan uh monday i was at a
larry elder rally which we posted the
video to on youtube and then the last
two days uh were rosh hashanah the
jewish new year happy new year to all
the jews i believe it's
57.82 that's a lot of years of annoying
bad people
so there you go anna you know apologies
to ilhan omar and rashid is even the
rest of the squad for sticking around
for so long what can we do uh but i'm
just beyond fired up to be back doing
this and ready to fight for larry and
there's so many things happening it's
absolutely crazy uh before we get to any
of that though let me do a quick ad for
bonner wine because i have been back and
i've you know i was doing tequila all
summer i'm back on the juice people if
you like wine like i do and you're
afraid to drink in the same boring
bottles you need to try the extreme
altitude
wine that comes from the mountains of
argentina imagine at your next dinner
pouring a glass of red wine that comes
directly from the highest vineyards in
the entire world that's six thousand to
nine thousand feet any higher and the
grapes wouldn't be able to survive what
does this all mean for the wine a flavor
unlike any wine you've ever tasted
blackberry leather smoke and a little
dark cherry this stuff packs a punch and
nature does all the work that means no
dyes and no flavor additives this wine
is almost impossible to get in the u.s
because of the small family producers
the family producers deep in the andes
mountains make a very limited quantity
just getting the wine bottles down from
the mountain unbroken is a challenge the
guys over at freethinkerwine.com have
cracked the code when it comes to
getting these rare wines to americans
the best part they've cut out the
middleman you won't deal with any big
industry markup listen i'm normally a
cabernet guy as you know but i really
have been enjoying these malbecs with my
steaks and we just made a freaking
unbelievable eight-hour brisket on our
smoker which if you're joining me at uh
reubenreport.locals.com you can see the
pictures and the videos actually visit
freethinkerwine.com and you'll get top
quality extreme altitude wine for about
half the price my audience get 50 gets
50 off the wine and 50 off shipping no
need for a promo code just visit
freethinkerwine.com that's
freethinkerwine.com
and now back to me okay so look
there's a moment happening in california
right now and as they say as goes
california goes the country well when
they say that that usually means oh the
progressive lunacy and the big
government and high taxes and regulation
and horrible education and homelessness
and all of those bad things that that's
going to trickle across the country and
in many cases it often does there is a
moment
for california right now and we've got
five days left to make sure we get rid
of gavin newsom who has kept us locked
up wearing masks out of work depressed
etc etc
and vote larry elder in so i want to
show you a video right now i'm sure some
of you that are more online creatures
have seen this already this is a video
of larry elder yesterday while he was in
venice california venice you know venice
beach right everyone knows famous venice
beach right muscle beach where hulk
hogan you know learned to lift weights
and it's just it was at one time this
incredible place of sort of hipster
cool funky music and all these weird
characters when i first moved to los
angeles in 2013 it was like the place
you wanted to go and the beach was
gorgeous and just cool people out there
and it was just so wonderful it has been
transformed into an abject disaster
because of the policies by gavin newsom
and by our mayor
in los angeles and in effect it's
basically just a drug den homeless
people everywhere it's an absolute
disaster well larry elder went to venice
yesterday to take a tour
and uh watch what happened here and i
know as i said those of you that are
more online creatures you've probably
seen this video but i assure you if you
watch cnn msnbc or if you read the new
york times or washington post you
haven't heard about this or seen it or
anything else
we'll get to that part of this in just a
moment but here's the video
hey
hey michael scott
okay so obviously there's a bunch of
crazy people and drug addicts there
that's what they've turned venice into
which is exactly why larry was there in
the first place but just to be clear
what happened there was a white woman in
a gorilla mask
threw an egg
at our black gubernatorial candidate
here in california now i don't care that
larry is black i don't think larry
really cares that he is black and i
don't want to play the identity politics
game but the simple fact is
if that was anyone that was a democrat
if that was stacy abrams if that was any
black democrat anywhere and a white
person in a gorilla mask had thrown an
egg at them then punched their security
guard there was a whole bunch of
other yelling and cursing and all sorts
of stuff do you think that we'd be in
the middle of a media hellstorm that
would be almost unimaginable and 24-hour
non-stop coverage right now of course i
don't even have to ask you that question
you know that we would so this is not
that some crazy person in a gorilla mask
did this specifically and it's not that
some other drug addicts and whacked out
lunatics uh are are attacking a
candidate right like people do all sorts
of real stuff of crazy stuff the point
here is the media is actually evil at
this point let's not pretend that don
lemon and brian stelter and
and anderson cooper and wolf blitzer and
all the rest of them that they haven't
seen it they've all seen it that video i
helped it go viral last i saw it had
over three million views it's it
completely caught fire online didn't
make cnn we checked didn't it's not on
msnbc's website not on abc not on nbc
not on cbs not on politico not on the
new york times
i'm starting to think guys call me crazy
and you know i was off the grid for a
while so maybe i lost it i'm starting to
think that our mainstream media is an
arm of the democratic party i'm starting
to think that the people who call
everyone racist are the racist could i
am i not was i drinking wine before the
show you think what's going on here uh
this is
it's a scandal because it's a
non-scandal it's the same thing with
biden and the dementia that's what i
always say the scandal is the
non-scandal okay again just imagine that
was stacey abrams walking out someone a
white person in a gorilla mask throws an
egg what do you think would be happening
right now but instead they ignore it and
you know why they ignore it because they
don't want anyone to hear larry elder's
message they're afraid first off they're
afraid that larry elder would look like
a victim and they love victims right so
they don't want him to be a victim okay
so that's number one but the second part
is once they hear larry elder's name
then they might google larry elder and
you know what if you google larry elder
although i'm sure google is screwing
with the search results you might start
hearing larry elder speak and when larry
elder speaks he's making sense and he's
telling the truth and he's pushing back
on all of this progressive lunacy that
has ruined this state and that is now
infecting every part of this country man
i'm feeling it today
you know what i campaigned with larry on
monday here in thousand oaks it was a
spectacular rally about a thousand
people there the crowd was absolutely
unbelievable democrats republicans
independents
people were fired up and ready to go so
i spoke before larry elder as did scott
baio so larry elder has me and scott
baio well newsom's feeling the heat
because he got obama to throw in an ad
and i want you to watch this ad and then
right at the very end i want you to read
the text that's going to show up because
i want to talk about who this ad is
funded by but listen to obama and you
tell me is everything that barack obama
is saying in this ad true
you decide hello californians you've got
a big choice to make by september 14th
governor newsome has spent the past year
and a half protecting california
communities now republicans are trying
to recall him from office and overturn
common-sense coveted safety measures for
health care workers and school staff
your vote could be the difference
between protecting our kids and putting
them at risk helping californians
recover or taking us backwards
protect california by voting no on the
republican recall
barry barry you're a liar you're a liar
barry let's get into it uh first off
he's saying that newsom's protecting the
kids he's been protecting us for the
last year and a half well if he's
protecting us why is everyone telling us
that koben's going bananas right now
obviously he's not doing a very good job
at his protections oh and by the way
there's no scientific evidence that
lockdowns work etc etc and every idiot
that i'm around here in los angeles is
walking around in 90 degree heat with no
one around them walking their dog with a
mask on okay so newsome no he obviously
he did some stuff sure he ruined the
economy depressed people got everyone
trapped at home people are out of work
and all that stuff but if you're saying
he protected us but the meme out of the
white house is covet is worse than ever
right now right 300 percent rising
so okay barry i think you're wrong about
that uh he then calls it a republican
recall well i just pointed this out and
i mentioned it in my speech that's on
youtube right now that i gave on monday
at the rally this is not a republican
recall this is a complete lie and meme
being spread by barack and and newsom
and the rest of these tools
there are regular people i have met them
on the streets i go to these rallies i
went to rallies to open up the state and
all of the people signing the recall no
i can't say all of them i'll be honest
unlike these freaks uh many of the
people signing these recalls these were
apolitical people it's not even they
weren't republicans it's not even that
they were democrats they were just
regular people who wanted to go to work
how about like uh that lovely woman from
pineapple hill saloon in sherman oaks uh
los angeles who wanted to just open up
her restaurant did all of the things
they asked her to do open up an outdoor
area you all saw that viral video did
all of the things she could do to do it
they closed her down outdoors while
right next to it they let a hollywood
production go on and they could have
their food and sit outside but she
couldn't i don't know that she's a
republican she just struck me as a
regular person so this is not a
republican recall this is that two
million people roughly hand signed at
the height of the pandemic when they
were telling you not to go outside hand
signed a recall that literally
if you were signing it and your pen
touched the line above or below would
would discount your
uh signature and you would not count
towards recall well about two million
people signed it those people are fired
up to vote like if you hand sign
something in the middle of recall you
think you're going to vote on the on the
14th on recall day yeah those people are
going to vote they are motivated to vote
and i think there's a lot more of them
now than there was even back when the
recall was happening so that was a lie
then he gets into common sense covet
stuff it's just common sense it's common
sense lock everybody down keep kids in
masks
yeah i don't uh common sense i'm i'm not
so sure about that but don't take my
word for it we're gonna we're gonna show
you that fouchy guy in just a minute
contradicting everything else he said
and everything else that they're doing
and then finally at the end if you
didn't catch it the ad is funded and i
mentioned this uh last week when i did
the q a the ad is funded by reid
hastings well who's reid hastings reed
hastings is the ceo of netflix and he
has been pouring millions and millions
of dollars into anti-larry elder ads
basically implying he's a white
supremacist and he's going to kill your
kids all over youtube i'm sure you've
seen these videos on youtube and
actually one of the only things that i
saw while i was off the grid when i
watch old basketball games is every ad
that i saw was an anti
larry elder although rarely would they
mention him by name the candidate that
you know the trump supporting candidate
who's coming after gavin newsom and the
republican recall so reed hastings who's
the ceo of netflix who also gave gavin
newsom 3.1 million dollars should go
check for yourself don't trust me uh is
pumping all of this money into ads that
are lies about larry elder you're not
going to believe this
guess who
got a multi-million dollar contract to
do a whole bunch of shows on netflix you
know who do you guys know
come on one yeah you got it barack obama
i can't believe it i can't believe it
guys i want to mention by the way i like
to mention this every now and again i'm
not a journalist i'm not even saying
there's something illegal going on there
but do you see how gross all of this is
it's all gross and disgusting why is it
that reid hastings the netflix ceo who's
probably worth hundreds of millions of
dollars why is it that he so desperately
wants to keep gavin newsom why is it
that he's pumping all this money into
this and then he's pumping money into
getting the president the former
president of the united states to do ads
on this and by the way he's also paying
the president of the united states
for a uh a production deal do you think
that there's something going on there
and do you think maybe when netflix
picks which shows are on that there
might be a political bent to them you
think you think some of that stuff might
be possible i think it might be possible
anyway i as i said the day i got back i
am devoting every moment of my time
right now uh to helping larry win and
look if it's me and scott baio and larry
elder versus gavin newsom barack obama
and kamala harris i like our chances i
really do so
bring it guys and and please if you live
in california please vote we know there
is going to be fraud we absolutely know
it now oh i should mention this
um i went to rosh hashanah services that
dennis prager conducts and and dennis
they were quite moving services actually
and i'm trying to to reconnect with uh
with that part of my my life and my
tradition and history and all that stuff
dennis runs a really wonderful service
and he makes a point of saying and he
said it repeatedly throughout the
service that he does not want it to be
political he does not want to bring
politics into religion he doesn't want
to use the the pulpit uh of his position
as the leader of service to do anything
political and he does a remarkable job
of it he really does and i suspect that
in most temples and in most churches in
america that's not happening i think
everything's become hyper-political
unfortunately uh but he managed to do
that but when i walked out of the
services
and dennis walked out you know basically
everybody that's talking to us in the
parking lot wants to talk about the
recall and tons of people who had
supported larry which is great but
everyone has this feeling
this feeling that
they're going to fix it one way or
another does larry have momentum yes are
the people sick of gavin newsom yes does
anyone like evan newsom no do a lot of
people like larry elder yes
but what are they going to do
california is allowing mail-in ballots
on the 14th 14th is election day that
means if you postmark your ballot on
election day they'll still count your
vote so do you think it's possible
and again i don't have all of the i
don't have the evidence because it
hasn't happened yet but like i don't
have every smoking gun or anything but
just like if we're just thinking people
knowing that politics has become
religion to people and knowing that the
democrats don't want people voting with
ids and knowing that there's all these
mail-in ballots and that you can
literally print your ballot on your
computer and that my friend colin
moriarty who's been a guest of this show
who left california two years ago he got
a ballot to vote while he lives in
virginia now he left over two years ago
i already sent that to rick grenell and
to some of the lawyers that are watching
this stuff but they're letting you take
um
mail-in ballots till the day of the
election so is it crazy to think that it
might be a possibility that come
election night if they're counting
ballots and it's kind of looking close
and larry maybe is winning do you think
the media might because the media
obviously doesn't want larry elder to
win they don't mind when a woman in a
gorilla costume throws an egg at him do
you think it might be possible that
they're going to be like oh you know we
can't call this election or just the
general california machine which who's
tabulating these votes it's the entire
machine the entire system here is
democrats so do you think they might be
like ooh that larry older guy's winning
uh sorry we're going to have to wait for
those mail-in ballots and by the way a
lot of them were mailed in today so
we're going to need five more days oh
and we might need a week and we have
been set up we have been set up that
that's just what i believe um but you
have to have hope and you have to get
out there and vote you have to do
everything that you can do and then
hopefully let's have some people
watching some of this stuff watching for
some of this stuff etc etc and by the
way then this uh
i just saw this on twitter uh this this
clown this guy john cox who's run for
governor like a million times here and
he always gets you know no votes or
anything he was just on cnn saying that
he thinks that he's a republican here in
california he's he thinks that um you
know even though larry elder said there
could be shenanigans he thinks
everything will be just fine and it's
like uh john cox do you know why they
put you on cnn because you're a tool who
would say something like that they would
never cover your candidacy but the
second you're willing to sell out your
voters and attack the the number one
republican in this race who's really a
libertarian more than anything else
congratulations john cox you got on cnn
you think they were ever going to ask
you about any of your policies or care
about any caring about you in any way
whatsoever if you weren't about to sell
out no of course not
going to have some water
guys i want to talk to you about raycons
you know after spending a month off the
grid doing my best to escape the chaos
of the world with tequila on sandy
beaches and in the rainforest it was
challenging to return home only to
realize that things had gotten more
bananas while i was gone ain't it the
truth no matter how you're feeling about
getting back out there there's no
denying it's an adjustment when the
world gets too loud something i love to
do is create my own soundtrack by
popping in my raycon wireless earbuds
sometimes you need some upbeat music to
pump you up before you see people or to
stay calm with some guided meditation
because my raikons travel so well i can
take them with me to listen to classic
nba games whenever i hit the gym or lull
me to sleep with some atmospheric
electronic music when i'm flying on a
red eye let me tell you guys right now
raycons are the best way to listen they
come with a bunch of gel tips for your
comfort and unlike some other brands
they don't stick out of your ears
raycons have a 32-hour battery battery
life so you can listen to what you want
when you want
for a really long time they start at
half the price of other premium audio
brands but they sound just as good and
raycons come with a 45-day happiness
guarantee so you can't lose give them a
try you'll see what i mean create your
own soundtrack with raycon right now
reuben report listeners can get 15 off
their recon order at buyrecon.com reuben
that's by raycon.com ruben to save 15
percent on raycons by raycon dot com
slash reuben and now back to me okay so
i guess we have to talk about this covid
thing
you know about this covet thing you know
masks and lockdowns
you know assaulting strangers who aren't
wearing masks oh this is a good one did
i mention this the other day on the show
i went i just told you i smoked a
brisket last week we've been just
crushing it on the smoker like i'm
smoking all this stuff so we go to get
the brisket i'm at costco and i it's
true and i don't want the authorities to
come for me right now we're gonna have a
knock on the door in a second they're
gonna
black bag me like v for vendetta but it
is true my mask was
beneath my nose i needed to breathe some
fresh air and there's nothing like the
fresh air of costco and i'm we're at the
brisket there and i'm looking around and
this woman comes up to me gets right in
my face like basically touching me and
she's like yeah now you know
the mask is supposed to be above your
nose
and i said oh i didn't know that thank
you for letting me know and she said you
didn't know you don't watch the news and
i was like no i don't watch the news
nobody should watch the news it's
terrible and she's like ow okay
and then walked away and it's just like
this is the absurdity of these people if
this woman was actually afraid that i
had covid which was being transmitted
through my nose do you think she would
walk up get in my face to tell me about
it so it has nothing to do with that
it's crazy psychotic lunatics who are
trying to exercise their authority over
other people like you'd be running away
from me you crazy [ __ ] you wouldn't be
getting in my face
all right let's talk about australia
though because australia something
insane is happening there i mean i'm
going to show you a bunch of stories
right now in some video here australia's
just
i don't know what's going on it seems
like they have just decided to just give
up in the face of rampant
authoritarianism so first off we're
going to show you this video this is uh
of australian grocery store because
people are just basically stocking up on
stuff and there ain't a lot of stuff to
stock up on so first let's show you this
look at woolies in hurstville
everything
is empty
literally empty
hey why is everything empty
is this going in the supplier and that's
how we
don't get any more
oh he's online supplies
wow
that's crazy man
everything is gone nothing
their trucks aren't coming in
okay so it sounds like there's several
reasons for this and i'm not going to
sit here pretending that i'm a i'm an
expert in australian politics although i
do love australia and i and i had such a
wonderful time there with jordan
peterson two greatest weeks of my life
uh and i love the people there and it's
so sad what's happening it sounds like
some of the reason that this is
happening is that truck drivers are
actually protesting the lockdowns so
that they're not delivering stuff but it
does sound like there's also just which
which is what we're having here there's
just like this log jam and getting
things places and there's less stuff to
go around and everything else but when
you see that that should put chills down
your spine because australia is a first
world nation just like the united states
just like england right and it's like if
supermarkets are going to start going
bare because people are protesting or
because stuff can't get there or because
everyone's locked down and they don't
want you going out and they want you to
order everything on amazon everything
else we got a big freaking problem here
um so we've got a quote here oh so let's
just okay so that's one thing that's one
thing getting a little ahead of myself
here that's one thing well now if you
think that that's sort of scary and
eerie and like oh could that start
happening here well australia is now
building quarantine camps we've got an
image right there i mean this this looks
if you look at what images
from nazi concentration camps look like
they actually look similar the layout is
somewhat similar it's quite quite
disturbing um we've got a quote here
sorry where's this quote from
uh let's go let's go to the quote from
the age actually uh construction is
underway at melbourne center for
national resilience that's what they
named this thing melbourne center
melbourne it's melbourne not melbourne
melbourne center for national resilience
the unwieldy name given to the new
quarantine facility in mickelham
with the camp set up to open by the end
of the year so it's a little unclear to
me and i would gladly uh take any of
your comments on this they're gonna
these are quarantined camps so that
means if you get covid they're gonna
send you to this camp with other people
who have kovid so that you will not have
covet anymore
would these people not be constantly
reinfecting each other and do you think
maybe and again i don't want to be a
crazy conspiracy theorist but do you
think maybe when governments start
moving populations into camps that that
could maybe lead to bad things and that
could maybe uh eventually expand the
definition of who should be in the camp
and why i mean should we start having
camps for unvaccinated people and maybe
just feed them fish heads once a week
would that be something that we could do
and if you don't think all of that is
weird enough okay and yes it is weird uh
well now
we've got some video here the australian
federal government is planning to
de-anonymize the internet to introduce a
social credit system for combating
online abuse this is the type of thing
that would have got you banned from
twitter or youtube two years ago if you
would have said this sort of thing that
there's a chinese social credit system
coming that basically uh if you say
things that are anti-government or
against whatever the mainstream media
narrative is that you'd get you know
banned from the internet or that you
wouldn't be able to take part in
commerce and that the government will
literally keep a score on you to see how
what level of a good citizen you are so
here's some video a radical plan to
crack down on social media abuse is
being considered by the federal
government for more nine's oliver hague
joins us live in adelaide ollie how will
it work
well good morning essentially it will
work the same as a passport australians
forced to submit 100 points of
identification like their driver's
license or passport when using social
media accounts like facebook and twitter
now police would have access to those
social media accounts and it's all part
of a crackdown on online abuse now users
could be liable for defamation suits or
even criminal prosecution and it's all
part of a plan hoping to deter people
from engaging in bad behavior now the
recommendations were handed down by a
federal parliamentary inquiry their
reforms that are being considered by the
morrison government with the chairman
saying there is merit to remove
to remove uh the veil of being anonymous
leila
so police
will have access to australian social
media accounts to stop bad behavior
all right so let's do just sort of the
surface level version of it oh well
that's pretty good because people are
mean online and online people who are
anonymous or mean yes that's true now
let's do the slightly uh
slower or under version of this right
the little deeper version of it uh who's
going to decide what bad behavior is is
bad behavior saying that you're against
lockdowns is bad behavior saying you
don't like a government official is bad
behavior saying you want your kids to go
to school um is there an ethical problem
uh in terms of privacy that the
government can just read all your stuff
you know there's a i think you can argue
it both ways and and i'll i should do
more shows on it i think there's a great
philosophical
legal technological uh series of
arguments around anonymity online right
like if you're a let's say you were a
gay person in gaza okay there might be
some value in you being anonymous online
so you can connect with other people
tell people your story maybe meet
somebody
all of that stuff and it's legit you're
under an authoritarian government
australia is supposedly a western
government people are allowed to be
trolls at least for now people are
allowed to post pictures of frogs people
are allowed to make fun of politicians
but really what they're saying is here
is oh we're going to combat hate and
again i don't love hate trust me i i get
more than my fair share of hate online i
assure you that i do so i don't love
that and sometimes it can be quite
annoying because i would say
even though i really don't look at
responses anymore 90
usually of when i would look at this
stuff and get hate it's usually from
anonymous accounts right very few people
will tell you that you're an evil nazi
right-wing lunatic uh when you're when
it's actually their picture and you know
there's some skin in the game so i
understand why that there's reasons for
anonymity and i understand why anonymity
also creates problems
but if you don't think that this is a
slippery slope sort of like building
camps for the bad people
then you know i'd like to sell you a
bridge we got a little bit more from
australia i mean it's just crazy this is
from yahoo news
residents in apartment buildings that
have been locked down by australia's new
south wales state health department over
covet 19 concerns say that they have had
their deliveries searched and have had
packages containing alcohol confiscated
if the amount exceeds the department's
prescribed alcohol limit so you're
locking people in their house and you're
saying to them you can't drink
okay now again we can all argue about
how healthy drinking is you know i've
been on this tequila kick and i do like
those malbecs but like so the government
is searching people's packages you think
that might be a problem in apartment
blocks locked down by nsw health
residents are having their alcohol
deliveries policed in accordance with
the department's policy which allows
residents to receive a ration of six
beers or pre-mixed drinks one bottle of
wine or one 375 milliliter bottle of
spirits
according to news.com dot a u you can
have six beers
and you can have one bottle of wine i
mean does any of this sound right to you
this has nothing to do with alcohol at
this point do you see there might be a
problem here it continues any alcohol
outside the limit is being confiscated
until lockdown rules are lifted
according to the report residents may
ask a clinician if they want more than
the prescribed limits i have no doubt
that doctors are being called left and
right uh you know i need my gin it helps
me sleep um
lordy guys there's something so crazy in
the system right now
and and i think we're all running out of
time to fight it
all of us we're all running out of time
and and what we need to link this back
to the front story is we all need it
right now i know you need it i need it
we all need it we all need a little bit
of hope and that's why the larry elder
thing i think is so important a signal
that could that could spread across the
country that could spread across the
world because people are being locked
down people are being having their their
personal items taken away from them i
mean
sent to camps really this is happening
yeah it's happening and we need some
hope right now
all right uh you know guys i talked
about start mail for a second free email
services like gmail and yahoo aren't
really free i mean everything's sort of
fitting today you pay with your privacy
in fact internet giants like big tech
bank on exploiting your data by selling
it to the highest bidder your business
plan google has it your medical records
yahoo can sell them to drug companies
personally i don't want to open myself
up to identity theft and i can't imagine
you do either that's why i suggest using
start mail it makes email feel safe
again start mail keeps email private
period every email can be encrypted even
if the recipient doesn't use encryption
so when you delete an email in start
mail it's gone forever and start mail
uses their own servers not amazons which
means they can't be put out of business
like parlor which is music to my ears
switching start mail is seamless too you
can easily transfer all your current
email data so there's no starting from
scratch start mail is also backed by the
most stringent privacy laws in the world
you get unlimited anonymous aliases this
feature protects your main email address
from spam and phishing attacks that is a
good reason to be on anonymous online so
when you're giving your email to a
company but want to protect your
identity start mail can generate
shareable alias emails so people can't
sell your info and they can't and they
can be deleted at any time with cancel
culture raging and big tech censorship
out of control i keep saying the way
forward is to build competitive
businesses that support our privacy
values which is why i value services uh
like start mail your cyber security has
never been more at risk email snoops and
scammers are taking advantage of the
pandemic as fishing has skyrocketed in
the last year i mean i know this i get
the crazy amount of emails i get on my
phone blowing up with with text from
lunatics
take control of your privacy with star
bale start mail before it's too late
start securing your email privacy with
start mail sign up today and you'll get
50 off your first year go to start
mail.com reuben that's start mail with
the t s t a r t mail dot com slash
reuben for fifty percent off your first
year start mail.com
startmail.comruben and now back to me
all right so a little bit more on uh on
kovid and you know i said to you guys
when i came back on the grid like i
really wanted to rethink how i'm doing
this show and all of these stories in a
lot of ways because it doesn't feel like
it's enough to just be like oh they're
liars and and we gotta just call out the
liars i want to figure out ways to give
us hope so we can get out of this mess
and i hope you're really feeling that
today you know what i'm dropping right
now
but sometimes we just have to call out
the liars and then and then then i guess
it's on each one of you and each one of
us to say okay well if i know that these
people are lying what am i going to do
differently in my life
to deal with it well here's some video
i think it's from msnbc of fauci
discussing vaccinated people who have
the delta variant and you know what i'm
not even going to color this with
anything listen to it and tell me if
something seems weird related to
vaccines and what we've been sold
now that we have a delta variant that
has changed the entire landscape because
when you look at the level of virus in
the nasopharynx of a vaccinated person
who gets a breakthrough infection with
delta
it is exactly the same as the level of
virus in a unvaccinated person who's
infected
that's the problem so those data were
very compelling
and that triggered the change in the cdc
guideline
so just to be clear what lord fauci just
said is that whether you're vaccinated
or not the virus level that you'll have
because of the delta variant will be
exactly the same okay so i'll i'll just
assume that that's true in this case
right i'm going to take his word for it
he's fouchy he has given us information
we must must believe it now we were told
that the vaccines joe biden's words you
know once you take the vaccine you can
get back out there do your thing then of
course the delta variant comes and you
know
and then the woman at costco and all of
it um but
that sort of sounds like he's an
anti-vaxxer in a way you told us that if
we all got vaccinated we're good to go
everything will open up and actually not
only did he do that you used to say 14
days to or what was it 14 or 15 days to
flatten the curve 14 15 days who's
counting at this point yeah that was
almost two years ago at this point um
that was before a vaccine had even been
thought of right like right at the
beginning of this thing there was no
chance uh and by the way when trump was
you know doing operation warp speed and
they were speeding up the vaccines
everyone on msnbc and cnn was saying who
would take this who trusts cnn the cdc
and who trusts uh trump and all of that
stuff now if you say that about the
administration you're on one of aoc's
list
but the point here is and i'll take his
word for it that if you take the vaccine
the vir the level of the virus his words
is just as bad whether you're vaccinated
or not well that sort of is telling
people not to get vaccinated isn't it
isn't it kind of saying well this stuff
that you sold us this bill of goods that
you sold us isn't what was promised and
on top of it
just now i think biden's having a press
conference this afternoon but some of
it's leaking they're saying that every
federal employee will have to be
vaccinated without choice and every
contractor that works with the federal
government will have to have all of
their employees vaccinated so it's like
the mandate is here and by the way guys
you may remember on july 30th the last
day that i spent online before
disappearing i was banned from twitter
and why was i banned from twitter
because i said basically that the
vaccines aren't working as promised
which that obviously is true and i'm not
telling you not to get vaccinated you
should get vaccinated if you want to get
vaccinated you absolutely should and you
should wear a mask if you want to wear a
mask and you should live in an
underground bunker if you want to live
in an underground bunker actually i'd
prefer if a lot of these people did just
stay there stay down there we'll send
you stuff care package um
but i was banned because i said
obviously the vaccines aren't working
and obviously federal mandates are
coming that got me banned from twitter
of course then i fought back and
fortunately because of
reubenreport.locals.com i had a way of
getting my message out there instead of
just being completely uh you know being
completely wiped away from the internet
in essence um
well it turns out that the thing that i
got banned for that eventually twitter
did apologize and they said it was an
error well that's pretty much what
they're all saying right now so dave
rubin the kreskin of youtube uh by the
way just a couple other quick crazy
coveted things here this is from the new
york post a new jersey student has said
he is barred from taking classes at
rutgers university because he has not
been vaccinated even though he's only
studying virtually from home
he was locked out of his rutgers email
and related accounts when he went to pay
his tuition at the end of last month and
was told that he needed to be vaccinated
even though he has no plans to attend in
person
do you think that this thing is
expanding
does any of this feel like it has
anything to do with kovid do i seem like
a complete conspiracy theorist to you
maybe maybe i do maybe i don't
but i dig you and i thank you for
watching guys part one and part two of
my interview with tucker carlson i
promise if you haven't seen this
interview this is tucker like you've
never seen him before he drops a couple
f-bombs that's right tucker carlson with
the f-bomb uh but just like like just an
hour of just truth and nuance and
decency
and it's just it was really like one of
the more enjoyable interviews i've done
in about a year uh so part one and part
two are up on youtube right now you can
watch the full hour is already up at
rubenreport.locals.com completely ad
free of course
my
speech from the larry elder rally on
monday is also up on youtube right now
so you can check that out i'm trying to
figure out
if i can join larry for any of this bus
story this weekend i'll be at the uh
they call it the crenshaw youth summit
is that what it's called the crenshaw
youth summit in houston dan crenshaw
congressman great guy
uh he is holding uh an event i think
megan kelly will be there couple other
of my friends will be there and so i'll
be in houston this weekend and then when
i get back monday and tuesday i'm going
hardcore for larry i will do anything i
can do possibly remind her you live in
california vote in person they don't
want you to vote in person why i don't
know
uh vote in person if you can and if you
can't then mail it in but try to vote in
person if you can and just and spread
the word man we got a chance we got a
chance and for as fired up as i was
today
you know if wednesday comes around and
it doesn't happen you know i gave this
everything i got and i'll probably be
somewhat depressed you know and not
happy and feeling
less hopeful but if in the moment
that that somebody steps out there and
says i'll do it i'll do the thing that i
don't want to do larry elder doesn't
really want to be governor larry eller
has an extremely successful radio show
an extremely successful column he has
done a million things he lives a great
life like i i know larry you know larry
loves his robe and his glass of wine
like larry did not need this he did this
because nobody else is there there's
nobody caitlyn jenner is a fraud most of
the rest of the candidates i'm sure
they're decent people but larry is the
guy that can do this and that's why
they're sending out barack obama so as i
said before if it's barack obama kamala
harris and gavin newsom versus me larry
elder and scott baio i'll take our
chances i like our chances let's fight
man so i hope you're feeling a little
bit of that fight with us go to
electeelder.com
throw them a couple bucks so that they
can go into these last few days strong
and let's see what happens whoo lord was
that a show
i'm getting some chipotle people all
right see you tomorrow